[Musique]
en direct de nantes nous retrouvons
françois de rugy président des verts de
loire-atlantique qui est assistant des
députés verts à l'assemblée nationale
bonjour bonjour
un mot sur la chasse d'abord le rapport
patriat est attendue d'ici le printemps
il doit tenter de mettre d'accord les
chasseurs et les écologistes sur des
points comme les dates d'ouverture les
limites du droit de chasse des points
qui font conflit est ce que vous pensez
qu'un accord est possible
eu égard à l'avancement des travaux
alors qu'il est à écouter sur la chasse
le problème c'est pas tellement d'avoir
un accord
le problème c'est que les choses
reviennent dans le droit commun
aujourd'hui la chasse c'est un peu une
zone de non droit on le voit bien avec
la loi verdeille qui est remise en cause
parce qu'elle ne respecte pas le droit
de propriété
on le voit bien avec les gardes chasse
qui sont sous la tutelle des présidents
de fédérations au lieu d'être sous la
tutelle comme n'importe quel
fonctionnaire de leur ministère et ainsi
de suite je pourrais multiplier les
exemples
donc monsieur patriat est un homme de
bonne volonté qui aime bien compromis
moi je ne sais pas s'il va réussir y
arriver ce que je sais c'est qu'il faut
que la chasse tout simplement reviennent
dans le droit commun et respectent les
règles élémentaires qui s'applique à
toutes les autres activités
alors à part ça c'est bientôt la rentrée
la série nationale vendredi exactement
les verts viennent de tenir leur journée
parlementaire dans le nord il a été
question du nucléaire bien sûr avec une
question est-ce qu'il faut une
manifestation contre les futurs
programmes nucléaires c'est la question
qui a été posée donc par les militants
écologistes dominique voynet n'y est pas
forcément favorable alors on a
l'impression encore une fois qu'entre la
solidarité gouvernementale et puis les
volontés des militants il semble y avoir
un écart là non je crois qu'il ya pas de
décalage c'est évident que dominique
voynet ne peut pas avoir le même rôle
que n'importe quel militant vert ou
n'importe quel responsable verts élue
régionale ou élu municipal à partir de
là les verts ont lancé l'idée d'une
mobilisation avec d'autres acteurs avec
le réseau sortir du nucléaire avec
greenpeace pour lutter contre un nouveau
programme nucléaire du nom de père que
nous connaissons bien dans l'ouest
puisqu'il devait être lancée au carnet
et que ça nous avons réussi a justement
justement quand vous parlez du carnet
qui a été arrêté il ya deux ans quand
les verts de loire-atlantique dont vous
êtes le président entend dire dominique
bonnet faut peut-être pas faire de
manifestations antinucléaires ils
doivent plus savoir très bien comment il
s'appelle alors qu'il est si on s'est
toujours très bien comment comment
s'appelle le problème n'est pas là c'est
que
la question c'est simplement de savoir
quelle forme aura cette mobilisation
c'est ce qu'a voulu dire dominique
voynet ll a voulu dire qu'une
manifestation en tant que tel n'était
peut-être pas forcément la meilleure
chose à faire qu'il fallait prendre le
temps de l'organiser
une date a été proposée le 28 novembre
mais rien n'est encore arrêté
ce qui compte c'est qu'il y ait une
mobilisation dans le pays et
particulièrement dans l'ouest où les
gens toujours réussi à faire échec au
nucléaire que ce soit à plogoff aux
pèlerins ou au carnet que cette
mobilisation existent pour montrer que
la population française est austin comme
le disent toutes les études d'opinion à
la poursuite du programme nucléaire en
france
alors vous soulignez tout à l'heure la
particularité justement de la bretagne
et des pays-de-la-loire parce que ce
sont des régions il n'y a pas de
centrales ni d'une usine de retraitement
selon la liste et la carte officielle
des sites nucléaires qui a été publiée
la semaine dernière on en voit en
revanche dans les régions voisines
par contre il y à des sites nucléaires
militaires est ce que la présence de
nucléaire militaire doit faire partie du
grand débat sur le nucléaire français
qui sera lancée en novembre
bien sûr la question du nucléaire
militaire ne peut pas être dissociée de
la question du nucléaire civil il faut
savoir d'ailleurs qu'à l'origine les
centrales nucléaires ont été construites
pour produire des matériaux utilisés par
les militaires dans les bombes atomiques
mais surtout ce qui compte c'est que la
surveillance n'échappe pas que les
centres militaires notamment l'île
longue adresse n'échappe pas à une
transparence et une surveillance absolue
transparente vis-à-vis des pouvoirs
publics bien sûr mais aussi de tous les
contrôles indépendants
alors ce qui compte pour les sites
militaires venons en maintenant à un
autre dossier qui est l'aménagement de
la loire cet été les écologistes ont
obtenu une victoire avec le projet de
barrage à chambonchard sur la loire que
l'état refuse de financer le projet est
donc à l'arrêt il reste cependant de
l'autre côté de la loire dans l'estuaire
cette fois en loire atlantique
le projet donges est autrement dit le
projet d'extension du port de nantes s
et les élus locaux défendent ce projet
est ce qu'il faudra l'arbitrage du
gouvernement là aussi écouter déjà le
ministre de l'équipement et des
transports jean claude gayssot qui est
pourtant un communiste qui n'est pas un
verre a déjà fait un premier recul qui
montrait que le projet donges est tel
qu'il était prévu surtout par la chambre
de commerce et d'industrie est soutenue
par un certain nombre d'élus locaux
c'est vrai n'était pas un bon projet et
nous nous continuons à dire que
le développement des linéaires de quais
de l'activité portuaire à donges est ce
n'est pas la bonne solution on peut
développer l'activité portuaire dans
l'estuaire de la loire avec d'autres
moyens
il faut arrêter de bétonner l'estuaire
de la loire comme ça a été le cas si on
veut garder un minimum d'espacé protéger
un minimum d'espacé naturel et un au
moins un minimum d'équilibré naturel du
fleuve
françois de rugy merci d'avoir accepté
de faire le point sur ces dossiers de
rentrée concernant l'environnement et
l'aménagement du territoire dans l'ouest
merci beaucoup
[Musique]